okay well before we actually get into
the agenda proper um we're not expecting
any fire alarms or
evacuations this evening but um
the event we have to evacuate just
follow me through the door you won't go
forward
and again uh welcome everyone uh
all the members of public that are
following this on youtube
and we'll start on item one on the
agenda apologies for absence please
questions from councillors ford
harding inch lock
and langford
item two on the agenda is to agree that
council minute the minnesota council
meeting on the 14th of june 21
pages 5-14
i'll run through them page by page and
then we'll be looking for a
proposal in a second so it starts on
page 5
6 7
8.
um i did ask you know can officers say
what they will be asking for
um has there been any movement on that
because there wasn't last night
uh we haven't had a meeting with the
developer yet but we are on the process
of arranging one
uh for the next couple of weeks and once
we have
an idea then that will be reported to
full council
uh page nine
ten sure minute one nine one
second paragraph um i did declare a
personal
interest not a personal increase
i did take part in the discussion so um
um i made two points and one i've still
waited for an hour to form so
i'll follow up that later on a week but
i if you can amend that please thank you
page 11
12. yeah sorry about this
um item 194
second paragraph it says following a
query that was from me
the chief exec chief executive
uh advised clarity would be sore on
whether an independent member's planning
application should automatically go to
um has there been any clarity
okay now any any studies that's
outstanding action
uh on page 13
and 14.
mr watson proposed the second option
does that
get all in favor of this show
thank you any against
an abstentions
[Music]
contributions i don't think we've got
any actual contributions but we have
we have one um letter
one submitted statement which uh achieve
exactly reader
all right thanks chair um so it's a
statement from hillary birch of the
biddeford community group
uh an informal a political campaign
group who cared deeply for the fabric of
the term
winston churchill said courage is what
it takes to stand up and speak courage
is also
what it takes to sit down and listen
hello members of torres district council
and thank you for taking the time to
listen
our local historic environment is an
asset of enormous social
cultural economic and environmental
value providing a valuable contribution
to our sense of history sense of place
and quality of life
biddeford community group needs elected
members of this council to pause and
reflect on the mixed-use consented
scheme at prince of warf
also known as easter water wars a major
regeneration
waterfront site for biddeford we have
serious concerns of the consented scheme
11262020 fulm
up to five stories in height built over
two meters high
flood defenses on fifth of february 2021
expert heritage consultees to the
council historic
england robustly contested that the mass
and scale dominance
and bulk of the three residential
accommodation blocks will generate
permanent high levels of community
and individual harm to the civic
significance
and setting of multiple designated and
non-designated heritage
assets these assets include grade one
listed medieval biddeford bridge grade
one
listed royal hotel multiple grade two
listed buildings and two
conservation areas for which biddeford
town center forms part
national policy planning policy
framework
notes grade one listed buildings as the
as assets of the highest significance
biddeford has not won the two grade one
listed buildings
historic england's 5th of february 21
recommended design amendments to the
three
accommodation blocks to reduce or remove
the identified heart
benefits historic environment were set
aside by the council
why has the council failed to protect
biddeford's historic environment
it is an unnecessary and alarming
failure
good design could enable high density
development to take place without
damaging the historic character
of biddeford town in relation to agenda
item 15b
the notice of motion from councillor gap
we invite the council to be part of
an east the water wars task force run by
biddeford community group
formed expressly for the purpose of
facilitating changes to the consented
design
of the three overly large housing blocks
in order to avoid or minimize harm to a
bit of its historic environment
it in the headlines on the 21st to july
21
liverpool has been stripped of his
coveted world heritage site
status unesco has said that the
developments have
resulted in a serious deterioration of
liverpool's historic waterfront site
the guardian reported that one of the
most visible signs that the council
didn't take its heritage
status seriously was the arrival in 2013
of three disgraces
right next to the historic three graces
to spoil in the postcard waterfront view
unless design changes are made the
approved three overly large out to keep
in
residential waterfront waterfront
buildings at eastwater wards
the historic waterfront of biddeford
will have its own three disgraces to
rival those of liverpool three disgraces
that would reduce the status of valuable
and much-loved heritage buildings as
landmark and focal features
biddeford deserves better our other
concerns about the consensus scheme
include insufficient car parking spaces
lack of public toilets the viability of
commercial units and the complete
absence of waste management plan
for operational waste required to have
been submitted with the planning
application and deemed critical because
it informs
the development design in terms of
making the correct amount of space
for waste if the existing
design is built there will be long
lasting catastrophic consequences for
biddeford
we are seeking the council's involvement
in the easter water wars task force
not as local planning authority but as a
council that needs to address the issues
and rebuild trust for those
citizens and wants to ensure that
biddeford is a great place to live
work and visit the council should be
demanding a better future for them
the attractive historic town of
biddeford
members thank you again for listening
thank you that's purely noted
michael iv on agenda declarations of
interest
well i'm sure everyone is well aware of
the procedure for
if you haven't declared please do so
when it
comes on the agenda item five
is an agreement a general item part one
on part two
but we need to have a proposal for that
mr newton seconded
president mcauliffe all in favor
that's pretty
uh item uh gender item six is to
consider correspondence or other
businesses especially brought forward
by the direction of the chair i haven't
particularly got anything although i did
receive a telephone call
from a member this afternoon suggesting
that i
should be bringing something forward but
having taken advice on that
the chief exec and the solicitor i'm
unable to proceed with that at the
moment
um there's one other
other right or two other items on here
obviously we've got um
cancer inches uh ongoing illness which
um
dude would you like to just bring any
members up to speed on that
yeah okay um yeah he's uh he's still in
an induced coma
and um still quite falling he's having a
tracheostomy fitted tomorrow which is
supposed to be temporary fingers crossed
and hopefully then he'll be able to be
out this induced coma and
you can start getting better a bit more
but thank you very much for your kind
messages
thank you well i'm sure i speak for
everyone when we uh
wish him all the best speedy recovery
and also i'm sure that i again speak for
everyone when i offer
councillor hudson our divas condolences
on the sad demise of
of her husband recently so well
if you would uh claire thank you we
and thank you everybody who sent some
wonderfully kind messages and thoughts
um i questioned myself
and i think others question whether our
students actually should be here tonight
but phil my late husband
said i had a duty i was elected to
represent my community
and i should continue with that work and
it wasn't helping him not being here
um so i'm here i hope i can keep it
together
if i'm uh a bit vague at times
my head doesn't always work quite as
accurately as it did
but um thank you again all of you
you have all been very supportive and i
thank you for the bottom of my heart
thank you
of your uh correspondence as united i
did speak to you this afternoon on the
telephone
visa be the crown prosecution's uh
decision
not to prosecute uh simon warner at
least be
the piece of world awards um
to do the reason why i wanted to be
brought up tonight is because
there is a time limit as i understand
i'm not sure about the time limit
about two weeks for the council to
appeal against their decision
as you know the current prosecution
service is under extreme financial
pressure
and there's been lots of reports about
how they are not pursuing cases
basically due to finance well the fact
that
sorry the fact that we're on youtube and
i'm i'm told
it's inappropriate to discuss that you
know whilst we're doing this
live what the decision by the current
prosecution service not
and that's now in the public domain the
fact they've made a decision
now in the public domain there's no
change that
that's the way it is and uh therefore we
as a council will we'll have to make a
decision
as to whether or not we appeal against
it or whether we go forward from that
and we have 14 days in order to i
supplied to do that
nearly four years ago now this has been
ongoing
um and that uh this is kind of a
combination
yeah yeah well clearly we can't make a
decision on that which is not a new
gender item but um
i suggest that you speak to the chief
exec tomorrow morning
um or from his court to see whether
there is a mechanism where it can be
driven forward
[Music]
i just don't pick up my paperwork
okay so uh gender item seven this is to
answer
questions submitted under procedural
rule a9
um there were three questions submitted
two from country to four
and one from country haynes so
presumably
you've all got a copy the only ones that
we really need to focus on this evening
is the one from councillor haynes
we just accept councillor ford's um
questions submitted under procedural
rule a9 and you can see the answers that
have been provided
um would you like to speak on your
um yeah this has been running on
taking over black is
from this council must be three to four
years
now i mean it's not a sort of crucial
issue but it's
slightly sort of irritating really so
particularly irritating as it appears
that the county council
hasn't responded to chasing by
uh julia legal officer so um
may i suggest maybe that our county
councillor for appleboro
thank you thank you
agenda item eight is uh making of a
great torrent and a weekly neighborhood
plans which is page of 15 to 25.
good evening
thank you very much for that um sorry i
should have said
that that ian
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm here to present to the court
relating to the making of the great
challenge
and weekly neighborhood plans following
dawn can you just pull your microphone a
little closer
is that better yeah and following the
successful referendums um the report
presents the results of the referendum
undertaking on the two neighborhood
plans um
and it's necessary for this council to
accept their continuing effect as part
of the
plan for the area the presented report
provides a technology of the progression
of the neighborhood plans from the point
of every designation
provided by this council to positive
referendums
which were held in june of this year
members will note from the report the
significance of neighborhood plans
and that when they are made effectively
adopted
they will become part of the statutory
development plan for the area
and thus will be influential in decision
making effective planning
applications for their respective areas
i said as set out in the report there's
no considerable
considered reason why the neighborhood
plan should not be made
members are therefore recommended to
improve the making of both
maintenance plans and also has set out
in recommendations dedicated to
publication of decision statements
which provided in the report of appendix
2 and 3
to the head of communities in place i
would also suggest that the minutes
deflect the council of congratulations
to
tollington town council and winkley
publish council
and other participants that have enabled
recommendations before
this council thank you if members wish
to
make any um comments or
ask any questions
there we go ladies and gentlemen any
questions you would like to ask dawn
will we can we do your programs yes yes
sir
yeah yeah okay good someone like
sorry professor newton's proposing it
the second that's
all in favor of acceptees
[Music]
okay
okay i'm moving on item nine stat street
officer roll pages 26
27 um finance this is the
finance manager section one five officer
um david hayes will present the reports
a very sharp report as members may be
aware steve hurst was appointed the
chief exec back in july
2002 and following that exercise um
it was a management researcher that took
place which appointed members
um officers at the senior management and
operational management level
however with a separate consultation
specifically for the finance department
uh which included this constant
restructuring exit which was recruited
to the position of the senior capital
accountant
that position included to the statutory
function of deputy section 1.5
the council's constitution requires it
that all statutory officer roles are
approved by full council
so we've got and also we're under a
legal opportu legal duty to have a
deputy section 151 i under section 151
so i'm legally obliged for the deputy
section 151 officer
so following the internal recruitment
exercise the decision was made to
appoint peter hudson
remember i'm sure most members will be
where peter is to as
so um the recommendation is that bowl
council approved the appointment for
peter hudson as the permanent deputy
section one five officer with immediate
effect
zoom on thank you david yeah
sorry ken would you like to speak on us
all i was going to say was exactly what
david has said peter's done a
first-class job
but he's been an acting deputy and
you know we've gained a lot of points
for the work that
um our financial department's done with
the local businesses
the way we've paid out the grant money
the way we've worked with local
businesses
so i think it's an automatic um approval
that uh peter should become the official
deputy 151 officer so
thank you thank you cancer you're
proposing that we've got a second
pete watson i'm sorry claire was it
yes please okay
on there to item 10 which is the
boundary review
um chief executive will speak on this
item
[Music]
thanks chase there's another quick uh
short report
um members have seen the reports of the
review of 2023 uh retaining the number
of constituencies at 650
but within torrh our electorate is too
large and needs to be reduced
um so the boundary has been the boundary
for foreign
um i did send an email around to all
members last week because
any responses need to be in today
which we will endeavor to get in should
there be any responses
but as yet we haven't had anything from
any member
in terms of a response
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you
item 11 is uh appointment of independent
persons
for standards committing
32 and 33 report i think stacy is going
to present this
thank you chair and again another fairly
short report
um but with a couple of addendums if
possible
um we we've long been without
um independent people that we've had one
and for a significant period
um we've struggled to recruit i think
this is the fourth recruitment exercise
that we've gone out
um we were lucky enough to have two
independent people apply
um this time um so sean carney the head
of community police and myself
have interviewed both um in consultation
with the chair
of standards council of laws they've
been to a standards committee and met
the standards
um members so i'd like approval tonight
if possible to
formally appoint them to standards
committee
um the caveat to that is within our
constitution
um we only say we're allowed to
independent people
but if members will be reminded to
change that to agree free in this
instance because i think it's really
important that we have independent
um people they're both suitable
candidates
um and in addition to that um
we're also short of independent people
for external
ons as well um so
it would be good if if council would
agree to appoint them
to independent people on external ons as
well
thank you that's the recommendation um
council james do you want to speak first
why did somebody keep taking my name on
stuff um
yeah i fully support the recommendation
uh the um are no part in the selection
but
they seem to be worthy candidates and
obviously the
more in a way the more independent ones
we've got the more
transparent it is so and also we're
lucky they're both agreed to serve on
ons
um so that's a win-win so i'm happy to
support the recommendation and recommend
it thank you
one second of them who's that
prince of laws on that show
abstentions
[Music]
okay item 12 membership outside
buildings which is page 34-38
um again stacy you wanna
very quickly obviously present this as
well very yeah very quickly thank you so
this was brought forward at the agm and
it was set at the agm to delegate two
group leaders to make the decision to
appoint to outside
bodies so i'm going to hand over to the
leader councillor james
it's been a slightly long process
because we have the list of names but we
have no connections
to the various organizations and there
was no point just having
people's names there not knowing what
bodies they represented or who the
contacts were
so it took us a while to establish all
that we've had a couple of
second goals at it i
yes i think we've got a member on the uh
on the tone council actually which is uh
i think yeah councillor john's travel
dance chair
i'm not aware that um that there's been
a member representative
to tibble there but there certainly has
been officer representation
i'm sure if you spoke to an attorney for
the chairman he would uh wouldn't object
if he wants to propose well i can take
that selection
okay and then leave it with the leader
to perhaps nominate someone
okay well without exception then um are
we
we'll just accept this
it does okay council james you're
proposing that yeah
second replace pencil wilson all in
favor
again or abstentions
sure country hits did you did you vote
on that
what they've contributed
yeah that's not a bad idea i'm sure
individuals can take that forward
uh right okay
item 13 is the uh annual report which is
pages 39-58
uh and council james the leader will
present us
thank you chair i hope that's my last
one
um yeah i i consider it a good report it
shows torrance in a very good light
it's been well laid out well presented
and congratulate john walter and
chris cox from the work they do i think
yeah we've done quite a lot and we
should be carried
and also inform our communities what we
are doing
so if they've got someone they want to
criticize at least
they've got stuff in front of them so i
think sex and rapport
i would recommend it to the rest of the
council
okay again that's going to be moving on
yeah yeah okay
second to this um all in favor please
show
item 14 petitions uh there aren't any
petitions so we'll move on to item 15.
notice there's a motion and we've got
two news's emotions
uh received from considers brenton and
gub
which one is the flashlight counselor
brenton
is the first with his motion mr brenda
thank you chair um this is
not often i actually look forward to
noticing which is sort of mother an
apple pie really
you you why anybody to vote against this
but there you go
um over the years many of you know that
we've had endless
um disputes and protests etc where
developers have tried to pitch bits upon
community land
or open spaces hardly a week goes by
with
in the journal without um some row of
people with uh with banners
we've had our own instances here with
with western hope you go back
further london dairy for example where
the developer tried to
develop on that big space of green in
front of those houses and
hopefully the community made it into a
village agreement and overcome it that
way
you know years before that old town
cemetery play area which uh
developers tried to get their hands on
and they locked the gates and said i
could bore you to death with the
examples but really now that we're
looking at
reviewing the district plan and because
open space is so valuable to the
community
whether say in this i've given you there
the
various people organizations that
actually have control of them
i do think we should have it in our
local plan that these areas
are in fact sacrosanct zero boris
johnson now
he said that we shouldn't be more than i
think 20 minutes away from a
first-class football pitch
and at the same time in the same article
we discovered that we've had about 126
witches that have actually been wiped
out in the period in the last 10 years
so
you know let's let's actually put the
meat on this and get it right
so i would say i'll remove this and
record any comments thank you council
brenton
um i'm sure i'm not alone in
uh having a degree of support for your
emotion here um
i think the sentiment i would share is
clearly the
the open spaces and the land which is
owned by authorities of council
would be relatively easy to um
accommodate what it is you're suggesting
i'm not sure how that would work with
privately owned
land even the land owned by the people
such as
you know washington but um uh
okay yeah thank you
just a question if we vote on this
tonight
and support it where will this decision
go and what will the actual status of
this decision be it's only a notice of
motion so that one has to go up to
another
committee and where is this going to sit
within our wider sort of planning
policy and planning execution surely we
can't
come in tonight with a unilateral
decision to change planning policy
throughout torridge i'm told this would
be the joint local plan working group
that would have to look at this um so
kind of brenton is this something that
you wish that group to
look at them look into yeah certainly
joe because
uh it is i don't think it's actually an
invention
because i think it's written in that
little and it's not about the
preservation of open spaces
and regard to your comments about us
controlling uh private land uh
developments i mean they're usually
included in our planning application
that they have to have
areas and they've got to stay that way
that's the point they're making
they must same with the house
association but we handed over all that
stuff to westwood
you know they came with these caveats
that these areas of open space
were to be there you know not for them
to be changed afterwards so
i don't think there's any contradictions
in this one
well thank you country vanderbilt as i
said uh you know i
i i think more or less in agreement what
you're saying here can't see you
do you want to speak that sure i would
just say
one understands the sentiment that
councillor brenton is is getting at
i have caution that we should be tying
the hands
of our plans committee in such a way
um given given a an example
perhaps where they are faced with an
opportunity
of adopting open space as part of a plan
next door to um ground that we have in
order to give up
that ground it may be that there's an
opportunity to to better
what we have but to tie their hands in
such a way
i don't think it is it is good because
it
reduces the flexibility i totally agree
the sentiment
that we should not be giving up
the square metering acreage or whatever
of the open space that we've got indeed
we should be trying to increase it
but by with a rather blunt instrument
that this would be
tying the hands of our plans committee i
don't think we do ourselves any favor
and we actually
reduce our flexibility to perhaps
improve
uh our spaces in the future thank you
chad
thank you sure president james and can i
just say that
the normal thing with the notice of
motion is that we decide on the night
where it's going and i will propose that
we refer it to the local
joint local plant working group to see
the feasibility and the implications of
any such thing um rather than it's not
for us tonight to actually decide
whether we support doing it or not we
have our aim tonight should be whether
we decide to refer it
to a further committee and so i will
propose that we refer it to the joint
local plan working group uh for them to
see how that fits in with our local plan
second journey
okay so you have about mr brenton
[Music]
the motion is referred to the uh uh
local plant working group
um been proposing second to never show
hands please in favor
or abstentions sorry i was only guessing
thank you and one abstention two
abstentions
thank you um
second notice of motion is uh counselor
gov i should have said right at the
start that um
those emotions apparently the proposer
and the second
can speak for three minutes and there
are five minutes of debate
apparently which is in the constitution
so
i didn't think there was anything like
that i'm told there is so counselor
um i would just like to let everybody
know that
while i'm asking for this motion i would
like to tell you all that
um as a counter my job is to carry out
what members of the community
want me to do i work for the community
not for myself um i i don't want to
really read it out because i hope we've
all read it out but that
is the reason why i have put this motion
forward thank you
okay we've got a secondary council of
dubs motion
and so brenton seconded okay
so that's another
well sure we don't normally discuss
um notices of motion in depth but this
is a planning matter that's been fully
considered absolutely
fully considered and i've never seen
such a
such a response to the application on
bronze report
the support was incredible to the scheme
and even councillor gov supported and
i've got
the comment that she posted online that
said i fully support this venture
it'll boost the economy it'll make an
eyesore into a beautiful place
fed up of looking at it as it is so
i'm going to propose that we don't take
this anywhere and certainly not joining
this group that
it's come very late on stage thank you
any other speakers
oh sorry coach christie and then
coachella brandon thank you
um well i was the only councillor on the
planning committee who voted against its
scheme
and i would vote against it again if i
had the chance
both hilary birch who you heard from
earlier
and the developer have both phoned me up
about this
and i explained to uh hillary birch that
once a planning application has been
issued once
it's been agreed on it cannot be
retracted unless porridge pay
not just the cost of the site but also
the cost of the
um development after it been completed
i.e the notional profit
and torridge wouldn't go down that path
as i understand it couldn't afford to
um the developer ran me up and said um
he wasn't prepared to change so i'm not
sure where we go with this because
the developer is legally he's got his
planning application
it cannot be changed now so if he
doesn't want to go down this path i'm
afraid there doesn't seem to be any
uh reason to carry on um
i think it was kind of brenton and then
councilman
i mean there are items in here to deal
with very let's just take
one example there are many actually but
one example is the car parking relations
i had written to the oscillator asking
about how that's going to work
because it wasn't clear i've seen the
heads of terms that we had with river
it isn't clear who's responsible for our
party
exactly how much they will be and the
liability that goes with it
and is it enough for that development i
mean
as i said it's just one example there
are others
that uh this way it talks about the um
this is a
waste disposal or your rubbish
collection for example
no provision for that anywhere in france
so i think there is a
there's so many unanswered questions
over this proposed development
but it needs to be looked into otherwise
we've
no use leaving it until it's all
happening and then say oh dude
don't fall back but too late
thank you castle golf
thank you um just to answer cancer to
gov
i've been your position when you
represent the community
and it's hard it really is odd so i
i do feel for another minute um i'm not
in support of your emotion counselor to
go
on the grounds of what are your public
speakers at the beginning
you know it's me the biggest disgrace i
ever left the wars on biddeford
was a catholic in may and that to me is
one of the greatest assets of liverpool
gained
now there's any foresight encounters
back then they would have kept the
cafeteria in may because what a tourist
tractor that would have been to benefit
and the heritage
of the port that we had but that never
happened did it so
the the late steve clark i take him out
of him he was definitely a visionary
there
um i'm not i am in support of the
development
because it's probably the single most
investment but if he's ever had in his
lifetime
and we want to see a bit of off his
knees back on his feet again and to me
this is a perfect
opportunity to do so um with the
development
i sat in the plans and it was in full
support
for a comment from a mr brend of the
hotel behind
yeah who owns a great one mr building
the royal hotel
i'm not even publicizing that but he's
in full support
of it it would not affect his building
and with the bridge
we've got to go with the times you know
biddeford needs to be picked up
you've got to embrace change and to me
this is perfect opportunity to embrace
change so
catch the girl there's nothing personal
to you thank you what you're doing but i
do not support your motion
okay any other speakers before sorry
custom
chair i'm not a bit of a man and i'm not
going to go anywhere near the detail on
this but as a matter of principle
this has been looked at in detail
by our plans committee all of these
objections or comments have already been
added
in front of our plans committee they are
an experienced committee
and they made a balanced decision
and that is it is not our role
or our place to now try to
undermine or allow people to
circumnavigate
the decisions of our plans committee
otherwise we'd end up with complete
anarchy and there would be
bug fights going off all over the place
and i'm afraid
we must stick by our plans committee uh
who are a very good committee and put a
huge amount of work in
this was very well publicized the
developer laid on a
a presentation for councillors
which many of us attended online um
and i find it extraordinary that it's
come back in this way
if i'm charitably i'd say it's sour
grapes because somebody didn't get their
way and i
i'm not looking at youtube either
thank you well i i think i'm on record
as being
sorry now i'll come to you in a second
i'm on record personally as being
against the development right from the
start but i i've listened to
in particular what country christian
said and i have to agree you know it's
absolutely spot on
it's a bit like shutting the stable door
when the horses voted
um i don't really feel that we've got
anywhere to go this but before i
uh bring it to a vote did you have your
hand up cancer laws
yes i did it's not referenced this one
it's referenced the previous
previous notice of motion when
counseling newton spoke
on the player areas and
then you took no questions i had my hand
up at the time
let me just clarify i always understood
previously that notice and
notice his emotion wouldn't be debated
has our standing orders
changed well apparently on our
constitution i was informed this evening
i
noticed a motion the presenter has three
minutes to present it the secondary
three minutes to speak
in support of it and there is five
minutes of debate i was under the
impression
that there was no debate but in the
constitution the revised constitution
apparently there is five minutes of
debate am i correct stating
let's just get this out of the way first
and then i'll come back to you and
if you give you an opportunity in the in
the
in the spirit of openness and fairness
right okay we've got a
note on motion no solution from cancer
go which is being seconded
um can i have a show of ass for
again so all again please
okay any abstentions
two exceptions okay well clearly that
motion is lost
coming back to the previous motion
coastal laws
was your opportunity now totally support
that we're going back to the working
group i think that's a very appropriate
action
but i just want you just to think here
because i have witnessed like a lot of
you
our green spaces being nibbled
and some of you may remember the
fight that westwood had to save its part
when we were clearly told it was in our
best interest
to let half the park be built on
and we would upgrade the other bug
chancellors
never fall for that i hope in the time
of this council
we will follow liverpool because
liverpool have decided
quite clearly that all their green
spaces are going to be looked after by
fields and trust right hopefully that
comes to this council
thank you for the opportunity thank you
okay item 16 and 17 is
uh so we need
to leave youtube um exclude members of
the public
oh yes okay okay so
can i have a soccer ball
so i'm proposing them from the chair
that we move into parts we're going to
have a second
person with golf all in favor